in other news the former Pakistani prime
minister Imran Khan has received bail
after appearing out of court in
Islamabad he is facing a range of
corruption cases Khan has rejected the
charges against him saying they are
politically motivated he also alleges
that there is a conspiracy to ban his
Tariq Ian South party let's go to our
correspondent who's live for us in
Islamabad Kamal so Imran Khan did appear
in court how did that go
thank you
yes indeed after driving from Lahore he
went straight to the judicial complex
where he had applied for bail in eight
cases and the anti-terrorism court and
he was granted bail till the 8th of June
his wife Bushra Bibi also getting bail
in the National accountability Bureau
Court which is the national
accountability court at the same
conflict she was granted bail till the
31st of May Imran Khan had said before
his departure from Lahore that he was
apprehensive that the government would
try to arrest him once again and a
little while he's going to appear in the
National accountability Bureau in front
of an investigation team that is probing
into the al-Qaeda University trust in
which the government alleged that Imran
Khan and his wife busha Bibi made
Financial gains however they have denied
those charges the investigation Will Go
On and it is likely that he will not be
arrested today but as you mentioned the
government exerting maximum pressure
blaming him for the violence which Imran
Khan says was agent agent saboteers who
deliberately provoke those people and
questioned as to how a handful of people
wielding just sticks could go into such
sensitive areas without being stopped so
indeed it will be interesting to see
what happens in the National
accountability Bureau where both Imran
Khan and his wife are likely to appear
so Kamal what happens next I mean does
this tussle between Imran Khan and the
government just continue
yes it is likely to worsen given the
fact that Imran Khan himself has said
and we have been able to confirm that
over 10 000 people that a party workers
supporters most of them who were waging
peaceful protests are under detention
most of the key party leadership is
under detention and every time they come
out on bail in one case they're
rearrested again on the floor of
parliament also there is talked that
Imran Khan has committed terrorism he's
facing multiple charges from terrorism
to blasphemy to corruption and what also
indeed the mood from the government
non-compromising and Imran Khan of
course saying that the government was
trying to ban his party so that they are
able to sweep the coming elections which
he doubts will be held which he doubts
that they will be held in October
okay thank you
thank you the first live in Islamabad